the continued bad news for the failed
former president Donald Trump
in an appeals court now says the
Department of Justice can resume its
criminal probe of the classified
documents that were obtained at
Mar-A-Lago remember once that search
warrant was executed and the documents
were taken
um seized the Trump side said we need a
special Master there's medical documents
in there there's privileged documents in
there special Masters got to look at all
of it and you know classify Declassified
just a complete and total mess
we are now moving beyond that as CNN
reports a federal appeals court is
allowing the justice department to
continue looking at those documents
marked classified seized from Trump the
emergency intervention upends a trial
judge's order over those documents that
had blocked Federal investigators work
on the documents and is a strong rebuke
of the Trump team's attempt to suggest
without evidence that materials Were
Somehow Declassified remember what
happened
the special Master said
listen
if you're gonna make this argument about
classification then make it and we're
going to move on very quickly if you
don't because the special Master said
which I told you uh two days ago
you give me a document that says top
secret
and you don't present any evidence that
it was Declassified that's it
essentially a cut the crap moment and
that is exactly what is going on here
the ruling was issued by a three-judge
panel of the 11th U.S Circuit of uh
Court of Appeals
two of the three judges were nominated
by Donald Trump this is supposed to be
quite a conservative court and it really
goes to show that the arguments Trump
was making in public were completely and
totally absurd
um perhaps the funniest line from the
entire thing
is quote for our part we cannot discern
why the plaintiff would have an
individual interest in or need for any
of the 100 documents with classification
markings and that sort of says it all we
can't figure that out as well it was for
Trump's Memoirs he doesn't read or write
Trump wanted to review the documents he
doesn't read or write they were for
Trump's Library the library is not even
something Trump is really thinking of
according to many insiders there's just
no reasonable explanation other than bad
ones he wanted to sell them he wanted to
use them as leverage horrible horrible
things that border on treason the judges
couldn't understand it either so the
investigation continues there is now an
indictment watch taking place we'll see
where we are another month or two from
now I often have a very hectic schedule
and I don't always have the time to plan
the exact nutrition of all of my meals
but our sponsor athletic greens just
makes it easy to make sure I'm getting
the nutrients I want I've been using it
for almost a year now and it's great ag1
by athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight I
just like the veggie taste of it
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make ag1 part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below